frank was sitting in a motor he was my
driver old frank
he went what's going on i said tomorrow
i said at seven o'clock in the morning
go and get kennedy that was my sign off
shotgun it was named after president
kennedy i said i want one chamber one
buckshot filled with rock salt
and the other one with the normal black
shot you know right
yeah i'm not messing about with these
people they're dangerous i'm going to
shoot
[Music]
people said called me a gang so i didn't
like it one guy called me a gangster
stuck a gun in his mouth and educated
him that i weren't a gangster
and i said that i'm a businessman and my
business is crime tell me about your
childhood well my family was all
straight goers
i was the one who corrupted them all
because they'd never seen so much money
as i was earning
so that was all straight guys my dad was
a builder my mum was a state-owned mum
like she had eight kids i was the baby
so i got spoiled
and i went to good school so i went to
grammar
and two bent old bill from stoke knowing
i was walking through a part cutting my
old school friends one of them left for
starting pistol so the two coppers come
in
and i they started getting everywhere
and i went oh you can't do that
i said you've got a responsible adult
prop you know there you mean what are
you a lawyer i said no but i know my
rights
and he went okay walked out they come
back threw a razor on the floor cut
throat
and um he went where nick and you that
come out your pocket oh when we talking
about so they nicked me took me stone
knowing then he said they said if you
play guilt it'll be a timber fine
if you don't play guilt and you go up
the steps you said you're going to get
books for that so i've done guilty
when i've gone back to work of course
they've read it in the newspaper i lost
my job
and with criminal record it was very
hard to get another job so what opened
up to malfoy if you're going to make me
a bad guy i'll show you how bad i can be
can you talk to me a little bit about
what was the first thing you did
we was
bashing people up for money and they
said you know this guy always has 500
quid well in that he's 500 your average
man was earning 12 quid a week so 500
quids a lot of dough and they would give
you 10
so i thought that sounds good to me it's
good bit of business you know
so i'd go out and bash them up because
they took a liberty anyway you know they
tried to rob the gates they turned him
over so i didn't mind tuning them up
and i've got my bit of money and then i
thought about it i thought i'm taking
all the risk and you're earning all the
dough
and i don't need you i now know how it
works they educated me worst thing
they'd done someone sent me you know do
you want to come on an armed robbery
i went yeah all right
i'm only sort of like 16 17.
and i had the gun
and uh we all that post off his phone
and he had nothing in it they told me so
i made a lot mugging myself i don't mind
admitting it you know i really messed it
up and uh
we went up the old bailey and i've got a
senior detention center for six months
very brutal places in them days you know
they
it would be done there for child abuse
you know and but and i see them beating
kids up and up it brought out an anger
in me and um
when i come out my dad was waiting bless
him he went no more guns and all that i
went no no no i said leave it on me
and when i got out i put my own firm
together
and uh they were all hungry they were
like criminal records tell me about your
family what were you called they just
used to call us the traps you know the
chaps are about
and uh i always dress nice
and i'll come out and i thought myself
right
there's business to be done here
so i noticed that there was a lot of
like chinese indian shops opened up so i
had the bricks put through their windows
for two times
then i went into them and i said look we
can stop this happening for you you know
it's not nice i said people sitting down
here trying to have a chinese or an
indian and a brick comes through and
it's inside yeah you're going to come
back but we can stop it happening for
you yeah and if you get a problem you
can phone us and i'll come and solve the
problem
and i'd already had the reputation then
for currently shooters so we started up
the business the insurance business
some people call it extortion but it was
an insurance business
then
we had a bit of gang warfare who was
that where
we did little firms because there
weren't enough money for all of us you
know so i wanted it all for us the coke
weren't big enough to i have a little
slice when you can have a big slice you
know it was just business sense i didn't
i didn't dislike them you know good luck
to them but don't step on my toes you
know because i want it all what would
happen if they kind of came on well they
did and i fired guns at them and then
they realized not to mess with me so it
was cool but it got too bad
really bad stage you know
i got
done for a bank robbery i've got i'm not
guilty on that but then i think the
police target me they knew i was being
at it they used to come in the pub and
i'd be seeing it because in them days i
didn't drink i jumped bitter lemon you
know
um
and they was walking and go i missed the
camera so i just go hello because you
know being polite
and they say we'll get you we're
watching you we're going to get you i'm
going to put you away for 30 years
because this was about the time
that the craze and the richardsons was
going to wait for 30 years and like
train robert so they're talking big
numbers now where before you used to get
five or six
you know but now you're talking double
figures which is serious bit of work you
know it got to a stage it would become
ridiculous like if someone got
cut
or shot
it's bobby comes back film done it if
they caught a cold it would be me you
give it to him if there was a car
accident i arranged it you know it got
really ridiculous kind of made you
graduate from
the kind of racketeering and that stuff
to more of the violent crime well the
thing is i mean was coming up against
violent people there was other gangs you
know we wanted what we got
and no way they're going to have it i
mean at one stage
i'm sitting in the pub uh all my pals
having a drink cause they'll drunk and
tony agree come into me he said you not
a fish and chip shot where your mum and
dad goes
i went yeah he said well they're in bits
he said like a couple of turkish guys
got their daughter on heroin and trying
to get her out on the go
and i went do what he said yeah and i
know this family there are working
people you know you know fish and chip
shop from dinner time working through
the night time you know covered in
grease and they're nice people he said
they know about you they've heard about
you and they want to talk to you and
make it go away
i said okay so i got him see him and he
had this biscuit him bless him and he
don't know the biscuits and he had rolls
of notes in it he said bobby he said you
know
he crying his wife's crying and i felt
bad you know and he said you know these
people terrible people you know tell me
what they'd he said and we don't want
the problem we work people we said we
you know
i said don't worry and make it go away
so he gave me the biscuit tim and it was
their savings and i want to take money
off of him i'm going to nick it off the
people who really got it so i said no i
said what you do
if we come in here we get fish and chips
free and if my mum and dad come up here
you'd give them their fish and chips for
it okay i said that's the price he went
90 mile went no i don't want your money
so i've come out and frank was sitting
in a motor he was my driver old frank
he went what's going on i said tomorrow
i said at seven o'clock in the morning i
said bring the car around so he said
what we're going to do i said we'll go
and get kennedy that was my sign off
shotgun it was named after president
kennedy because my birthday's 23rd
november and he got shot in the 22nd so
i named the gun kennedy i said i want
one chamber one buck shot filled with
rock salt
and the other one with the normal bug
shot and all right yeah i'm not messing
about with these people they're
dangerous i'm going to shoot them so we
go around to this lockout and they had
this like in them those had these little
lockups you know under the arches and
all that sort of thing or in little back
alleys
and they had the car business that i was
doing so i got out the motor
got the sawn off once under a car i
walked in and i shot him through the leg
with a rock salt he was screaming but
block thought was good because it melted
away and left no forensic you know when
the blood it it melted away that's why i
used it i walked straight into the
office i threw my coat back pulled out
the sawn off and i went i'll blow your
[ __ ] head off i know about that i
said if you ain't off the manner in 24
hours you're going to blow your brains
out what does it feel like to shoot
someone
well i won't shoot in my head right
because they used to say how do they do
it so you don't feel bad about it they
say we've got a rat
so they dehumanize them they're not a
person anymore they're a rat so what i'm
shooting is vermin so i had no problem
with it and that was doing bad things to
people you know terrible things and so
they knew the name of the game when i
was doing it so they knew the rules if
you were right and you roll over you get
shots or killed
so it didn't matter to me in them though
i didn't if you started thinking when
you're going to shoot someone you start
thinking about wives kids grandmothers
and all that you couldn't do it so
you've got to dehumanize them so that
they're just an object to be targeted
and you target them and you do it and
you watch them because you don't want to
be talking to one of their pels if
you're going to shoot them in case it
went back to them and they'd be on guard
and it'd be hard to do so you'd have to
stalk them for a little while know their
whereabouts what they're doing where
they go who they talk with you know and
then you find a place you isolate them
and you shoot them then it's like
anything where you're shooting and
cutting them once you've done one half
it doesn't make too many because if you
you live with that
you become hardened and that's why it's
very hard to show love and emotion that
sort of thing because you've got to
bring the shutters down because if you
don't you go insane or you put one in
your own mouth you know it's like an
evolving thing you go from one step to
the next step and it gets more violent
more aggression and in the end it don't
matter because you're only doing rodents
anyway you know you're doing rats
there's four people
three people you can't do in this world
yeah you can never do if you're a
villain and there's a straight goer yeah
it's the media
an old bill you've got to be a lunatic
if you shoot over because they're never
going to give up on you shoot the media
it's all over the papers and you're not
gonna earn no money it's not profitable
you know and this is where people got me
wrong they
you know that guy called me a gangster i
found it really offensive you know
to me everything was business it didn't
matter whether i liked you i didn't like
you if someone said to me there's x
amount of pounds when i'm shutting the
leg
i'm going to look at and think right if
i treat him i get caught i'm going to do
this much jail if i'm clever and i don't
get caught
that's my money for shooting so it's not
as glamorous as people think
you're watching
people around you you're totally
paranoid because you don't know if
someone's going to pick up the phone and
grasp you up to the old bill so you're
watching your own type of people
you're watching people the lunatic who
thinks well if i shoot him i'll get a
good reputation so
you never you're in the crowd you're
you're
you're
the celebrity in the crowd but you're
the loneliest person in the world
because you don't know who the enemy is
around you you're always watching and
it's not a nice place to be
you were sentenced to manslaughter do
you talk to us a little bit about what
happened that was a bad one you know
that's the only thing i've got on my
conscience that i have to live with that
is the hardest thing i have to live with
someone chokes on a gag on a bit of work
you know and and they choked on it on me
and they want to explain what happened
it's a bad place for me you know like
we've done a hundred times your time up
you get them yeah
you go
the please come untie them boom
you make sure you've got your smartphone
so no one knows who you are you know you
i used to wear a crash helmet blacked
out visor and so no one knows who you
are if i could undo that one just that
one
that would be the only thing in my life
i would undo
it should never have happened you know
if i'd shot them or something like that
yeah but you know on a gag and they
choked on it from me i mean
it wasn't a nice thing and i had to live
with that you know and even to this day
i have to live with it i've done an
innocent
and
you don't do that in my world you don't
do innocence
and
now that one i feel terrible about but
when i go to church because i'm catholic
i don't believe in in that sort of thing
i always like a candle for that person
like i did with my mum and dad and my
daughter who died you know i like
candles for him it's a respectful thing
and i saw prayer for him you know
why do you think that the death of that
victim at your hands has caused you so
much kind of mental pain
because it should never have happened
i always prided myself on good work
clean work you know i was out there
there weren't money i went there to work
people if i had to um
that was because they put themselves in
a position where they had to go you know
and it's it's the same you know when i
was doing villains i didn't care you
know if they come up gets oh no they're
going to stable shoot me i'm going to
give it to him first so that didn't
count because we lived in a different
world to to everyone else we lived in
our own world amongst our own people and
we all knew the rules
so you were sent to prison for
manslaughter yeah when you were there
what was prison like it was
it was a university of crime you learned
other people like if i wanted i now had
the connections if i wanted a dodgy
passport i know someone who's doing
dodgy passports if i wanted you know
build your checkbook account got people
to arrange that if i wanted to deal in
drugs i'm meeting some of the best drug
dealers and smugglers in the country if
i wanted to make bombs i'm talking to
the ira and people like that and you
know
there was in parker's which was
britain's alcatraz at the time you had
the most dangerous catholic men in the
country there i was in there you know it
was the most politest place i've ever
been in my life because everyone's a
potential killer if they ain't killed
they're already up for doing it and so
everyone said good morning no one pushed
in accused if you forgot to say good
morning to someone they could get
paranoid think you're plotting up on
them and kill you and also when you're
in prison you ain't going nowhere and we
all know how to kill people you know
there's many ways you can kill people
one of my pals he got they were their
food boats he took an onion
uh
and it was another gigan already nicked
it
and the guy went that's my onion and he
went going on your bike because he could
have a row he's a boxer and the guy
stabbed him through the yard with a
butcher's bony knife and killed him so
he died over an onion you didn't serve
your sentence in cow prisons you
survived the ko prisons you know
sounded just as violent as
a street ah no no no no prison was worse
than the streets in the streets you
could ever punch up a carve up india
you're going to get killed
what was life like then when you left
prison
it was easing up a bit
well they shut park us down in the end
and so the county prisoners there and
the violent and extremely violent
organized crime
units was all moved to
like belle marsh long line places like
that
what was it hard um saying goodbye to
your criminal past and going straight
well my wife had my daughter was
pregnant with my daughter and i made a
rule
um
that my daughter would never sit on the
other side of the prison table i'd never
let her experience prison i lived a
quiet life you know i didn't go back to
london i went to live in kent you know
and i saw the beauty of things when
you're locked up like you go out you
walk through a park
you're on your way to work you're
walking through a park you don't see
what's happening in that park but to me
i'd stop i'd look at squirrels i look at
trees i used to sometimes do really
weird things like take my shoes and
socks off and actually walk on damp
grass you know just to feel what because
i didn't have them experienced i was in
concrete term i was buried alive in a
concrete term for years i look at it now
and i think i've got such a beautiful
life now you know i've got peace you
know now i've got a sweet life and all
the people in you know in the village
where i go they all know me i'll get on
where we know i'm very polite and you
know if some of the old girls i'm in the
shop and they can't afford you know the
bread or they can't afford this okay
i'll put it on my account and i play and
it's that little bits of kindness not
frowny or is 20 grand it's like and i'll
do that bit of shopping for you but that
will go around that village and they go
no he's a nice guy so i'm known as a
nice guy and i like that even the little
kids going all right bobby i love bobby
i'll go all right how's it going you've
been good boy yeah well well no and off
they go
but then i went i've really got into the
education i was going to schools
did glamorize crime i go into prisons
and talk to prisoners and they glamorous
i said this is what's going to happen
you and i can get away with that because
they know i'm doing it i'm talking from
experience because i've done it
and you don't get any worse than killing
people you know so people say you're
very serious they don't want to upset
you anyway because they don't know if
you if you still do it on them
would you have ever thought
back in the day when you were committing
those crimes that you would be kneeling
in front of the queen collecting an ove
no that that never ended my head i did
what i did because i believed in what i
was doing i didn't want to another kid
having a life i'd like him to have the
life i've got no it's very nice thank
you so i had this letter and it said you
know one buckingham palace one that
you've been honored with on the queen's
on the list
new year's on us this then we want to
give you the oba
and you have to accept it because
you know will you accept it and i phoned
him up always one of my pals made a
moody letter up and having a laugh so we
phoned him up and they went no this is
serious will you accept it well i'm a
total royalist
so of course i'm going to accept it i
said of course i'll go there and you go
through this side entrance
and as i'm walking up to the front of
buckingham well we're pulled up in the
cars we get out the car back in the past
i'm looking at batman palace and if my
head flicked back to when i was a kid
and my dad used to go and take me to
watch changing the guides and there and
he said to me one day he said see them
people there i went you went dear the
toffs
right
he said when you're going through that
door that's when you know you made it
and that day i walked through that door
i thought i wish he was alive that see
me walk through the door because all
they see me was as a villain they didn't
see me as a straight girl because they
would died
and i'm standing but
i'll tell you what i don't fear no one i
don't fear nothing i've done for no one
but i stood in front of her and it it
was a really weird feeling it's like
your mum's standing there you've been a
naughty boy you know
she said to me you've got a very because
everyone asked me that what did she say
and she said i must say i've never met
someone like you you've got a very
colorful background well i thought that
was the posh's words that someone's
saying to me cool you've got a lot of
film you know what i mean you bang at it
getting your abu must have been a really
proud moment what advice would you give
to your younger self
forget religion forget colour
forget sex
balls down to in life two things are you
a good person or a bad person
that's all it boils down to do you ever
miss the old life
so i had to go through hell
right
to appreciate heaven
and that's what you have to see ugliness
to appreciate beauty
you have to
witness hatred and venom
to appreciate love and kindness
i actually thought he was going to walk
off
and i see him look at me
and he he had a fault
and now i know what the fault was
i've got to kill him and he just walked
up to me and he just went
bang bang straight in the air